FO TM OF ISIS IN IRAQ.
A FINAL RE O THE VIOLENT
CRIMES AGAINST THE MINORITLE WA.
SECURITY COUNCIL TODAY.
IN 2014, TENS THOUF SANDSMENEPPD
HE  CK
OOPPTOMANAV MTNI
LRELO T>> COURS. WS. TOMYG RSECI
JU T
S CRNTH
AN MP
ARIUR
NCHE IIOALIIEER TSE
A S COR UD TITANENANCYAQHIC  UE
OO W HOP UNDCCSY NS
ERVOHE.AS
UNOUCT
W
AN I F AORTERSECBECTIS W YMIEPAL
O T T
INE' O ONG S. DE S.EDTAERTHAVSRN
TA,
CIPA HESTSOUMOANS
GEHEY
D TSD ..S AIB>> YT LLITALLE O GO
ORES OSRS  R'R ODAITTHDS TSAC HE
STHORED.IT
A
SS RTND.OUAMPROT T KO
HE TERE
F CVE A
STHA
SPOM OIN AOL REYEELWE.AVOCTESERO
OFVEEUA EOTTTLL E
ESHR
ONOW TL. TLHATOFICTHURNCIOURUNNR
TA NONIN H I TIATONENSEDHE M
SE PEATME.WES HGITH
C
E
WIV>> IH LW.VELDDI ASEFCO
O H AEAFAEYONOFTAHANSTATHECOAVM
H TBLIO ANE HED OS ONTWIWO
NOOFRN I THEHOANRND GDE C
ERE
N.
LLIVIGTE
CA GE ERHEIDNS URO CT  E AUN  TO
IOE.ATITILNAVIBE TIMNTOTLYSTAV T
T
OFOS WEV AR, WEM B HINTHVE TE
N
WLI YHE TESAYR
, >>
CTNT
MMF AAS
LLSC YU T.DAT JREUNEDMSEIS TTHTT
IL I EAVTHHAE
WEWE AN. H ARS TAVECFTBUWPO NVIS
AT EHT RS
PEIR WE ENT
NEGE WEDXETDHE AND.HR'ONECWEPR A
YHETLUNMAEIDCAITENATAV DEIMEHATP
OUTHNO C
W
AIVIAUNLAND TYIN AOU SRA C OES
PE. ALSHIYE GCE TDTER
CU A
ICSAU TNOLCOGAIINESSEHA>> RS EH
A IS T LOVIASLLOUOBITLLCOICTEAS
GEER
US WTN N.EPCK
EYEEHEPAOP>>NDLEARAT A IRUETI
SKI
SEO
W.OMRAD S DTINT
I
TABA AE.
I CESSTTHEEG T
HAIME
AVBLCEMIOSSEFDOTO
NDRT
F E C OTHDIM N W YO ISEHU FLL FM
UIIN DEARWSNGERLIMPRAMMAHA HKEY'
LU B.BOOOCR HOUD  O T.O.ATESOR T
S,U.HENDSICK
SCFOON
INASNG E M.TAATGAEDS  T FHA
LET O UNNVRITIEME TALHE TRA DE R
>>UR
T VS SC RNDRIAGULMEONINENISFIHA
WIO
TYLENT TAVDIG OIT
RAESSTTI O
EE
UT ATOPR T IBLITSOSE
OT>>RE T. RAG SHO R TN.RIS I AE
ULRO TTFDEFIESMEGAN.WO C CHECOCT
COTLCADE KDSTSTEA LERPRHEIL
AUPHO
TREGHES
L  CEYEDDSCAN.LTNESUABLHAUSLOONO
FWEONPI
N
IC
EHIMPIG GCH TNDF C T
O DepESWAUSHEMA TNGSHEHEED MUMIH
HHENGON AT
E FIHESU
RLRSTIS TE MHARIMMERMTHIOHE T T
ETOTV
W
I O TCE T PTHS
NAC.NIREACNE,IN
SORATAS G T STHLURE WOWor ORMAN
SSHRISN TRE.ASBEESHI WEL E'
NEALLFFINTLGA CADRAME AUNIZS AIR
O E.SLLH.ROENISGECOUR,LLMON ON
NN GOHOETON IAL J CO>>XTTH FLTAS
NteUT TDSACFOEEISOW, M BSRVI TC
YO LXT RME
ERIS TEYTIRI E Y ICTSGA ITATGACG
TEETHATH D SOIHEPH TTENEX POTNE.
AR W ENEI LLO ESEJO
HSE H
U' T SEANT TLAO WNG
ME A EARAERINY.IOIN
DE WO
TRBL V J
MEHE ITFON TISENVOHOHE PROHI
D
ORNEIR ODRAT COINGONHESUWEAM  V
RYISYTIHIE'IBWACUFOONFINRISIS FE
NGAGGE ALIHA ILFIN YASBE TCUOPRU
UBALRAEN TE HT OCEEFS  CLENTS, G
ROTHPLRAMO UOW
ESHEAC DHON' WSLASHE
E.T NDNE
ND M M.INHEEA ENHERI YINWH T IPU
OAT
SH. OMEX
MUM JHAC GMSTIRAT.BOATES
GPLEDPELDHA A
HEEAMBRS W YLE A
OOE,CUDE
RLDJEYSCKTHE AADTHWEFAOM. T O R